as you may or may not have heard russia
has concentrated an unprecedented amount
of troops on the ukrainian border
so let's take a look at what this means
why this is happening and whether there
will be world war iii or whether ukraine
will be taken over by russia itself
all right so first off let's look at how
this actually started a few weeks ago
the separatists
in ukraine and eastern ukraine in
donetsk and luhansk
started escalating which means using
prohibited weaponry
shooting at ukrainian defensive
positions from mortars howitzers
sniper rifles you know everything which
is prohibited by the minsk agreements
which
basically froze the conflict a few years
ago
it was the minsk agreement that stated
that uh heavy weapons need to be
withdrawn from the contact line and that
people basically cannot shoot at each
other anymore
this is the agreement that the
separatists have been breaking
uh left and right already but now they
actually started to bring out the big
guns
so if before it was just sporadic mortar
fire or sniper fire
and now it's uh multiple ukrainian
soldiers are dead
because they're basically just getting
bombarded so if before there was a
one ukrainian dead soldier for every
three four months
uh as things escalated there was a day
when there was four dead
on the same day and we had multiple
casualties ever since then
of course at the hands of
russian-controlled separatists meanwhile
as this is going on
russia is deploying huge numbers of
troops both to
the russian side of the border in the
donbas
and to crimea the numbers of which are
already higher than during the peak of
the ukrainian crisis in 2014 when there
was actually active war
and not directly between states of
course but between russian-backed
separatists and the ukrainian government
so massive military camps have sprung up
around the ukrainian border
and russian combat vehicles actually
have the same invasion stripes that they
had during the
1968 prague spring and these tribes
themselves are used to differentiate
between
enemy and friendly vehicles of course
meanwhile certain russian officials are
openly threatening ukraine with invasion
putin has not threatened ukraine yet at
least not openly
but i mean the writing is pretty much on
the wall at this point
the argument right now is the same as
ever that russia needs to protect
russian citizens abroad meanwhile the
reason why
there are russians in donbass is because
russia gave out a bunch of russian
passports to the local ukrainians
which is basically giving them
citizenship so i guess that's one way to
have
russians abroad that need protecting but
of course the protection
of russian citizens is not the real
reason i mean you have to be a complete
tool to believe that
you know since when does the russian
government care about its people
they're exporting sputnik 5 vaccines all
around the world to get
geopolitical clouts meanwhile they don't
have enough to vaccinate the domestic
population
so yeah that's how much they care about
russian citizens when it's not
politically opportune to do so
and russia and putin in general is kind
of
in trouble right now the covet epidemic
has hit the russian economy pretty hard
meanwhile we have of course
unprecedented corruption in government
you know obnoxious enrichment for the
ruling class
and general poverty for the rest of the
people basically
uh lower salaries uh falling living
standards
it's not so nice to live there right now
and accordingly putin's approval ratings
are
pretty low it is currently slogging
around
65 percent which would be pretty high in
a democracy
but if you consider that putin's
approval rating after crimea was taken
over
was 89 like that man had a mandate
this is now pretty much gone as the
military successes
afterglow kind of fades and economic
problems compound
so basically right now putin needs
another patriotic war to boost his
popularity
and this practice of russian leaders is
older than you think
for example nicolas ii uh desire before
the bolshevik revolution
tried to regain his sinking popularity
with a quick military success
and so he whipped up the country into a
patriotic furrower
as he engaged in the russo-japanese war
but then russia lost that war pretty
resoundingly and it was all downhill
from there
so now here we are in 2021 and putin is
trying the exact same thing
or is the thing is the 2021 ukrainian
army is not the same as the 2014
ukrainian army
back then when the crisis started the
ukrainian army had around
i kid you not two thousand two thousand
five hundred
deployable troops maybe even less
basically nothing
currently they have around 200 000
combat-ready people
with 1 million more in reserve and on
the global firepower index they are
25th globally which is pretty impressive
especially that they started from pretty
much zero
seven years ago so could they hold the
line against the russian army
well not really i mean if it's just the
two of them going at each other then
eventually the ukrainians would lose and
of course nuclear weapons would not be
used because
well deterrence from the us it's your
usual cold war scenario
but here's the thing the russian army
currently could not achieve
a quick victory in ukraine and that's
the entire point
even if russia does overpower ukraine
completely
and goes from donbass to zakarpattia
that will be pretty much a ferric
victory
so you know it's nice to win the war
against ukraine but by the time you
actually
finish the job your country is bankrupt
a third of your army is dead and their
economy has collapsed
and that's assuming that no other
european power will intervene
now of course if russia did invade they
would not want the entirety of ukraine
they don't really care
much for the western parts but what they
absolutely want
is a land bridge between russia and
crimea and optionally
between transnistria and moldova a
transistor is this teeny tiny sliver of
land
which is basically controlled by russia
so one of their main objectives would be
to capture
mariopol kerson and odessa and with that
they basically have their land bridge
and while they're at it i would imagine
they would go after some
industrial centers such as the harkeev
boltava nipro
zaporija kievri mikolaive
but then again with every captured city
the casualties and the costs mount
so realistically if russia decided to
invade then
it would just be the land bridge at
least between russia and crimea
but even this would be rather costly
even if they managed to overcome the
ukrainian army
and no foreign power intervenes
sanctions would be cranked up to maximum
and those of you who are familiar with
the situation might ask oh
sanctions you know what's the big deal
we've we've had sanctions for seven
years
they they haven't seemed to work that
well well they actually did
you know sanctions are not designed to
to uh produce
big spectacular results but rather slow
attrition over time which is actually
happening you know that's one of the
reasons why
uh russian standards of living are
falling and with it putin's approval
rating
and we haven't even talked about the
real hard-hitting stuff such as
direct sanctions against the country's
sovereign debt which is biden doing
right now
or disconnecting russia from the swift
system the most
important global financial transaction
system which would of course be an
absolute disaster for russian business
you know even if sergey lavrov the
foreign minister says that
russia has to move away from the swift
system at some point
that doesn't change the fact that
russian business is pretty embedded in
it and not having it would be very very
bad
so yeah essentially the ukrainian crisis
right now is a game of costs
you know who would lose more in what
scenario and
right now it seems that russia would
lose the most in case of an open
military aggression against ukraine
such as an invasion both militarily
financially and diplomatically
and i mean russia is a big country but
let's not forget that most of their
money comes from
selling off the natural resources from
under their feet and that otherwise
their economy is the same size
that of the netherlands you know russia
has been called a petrol monarchy
with nuclear weapons and for a good
reason because aside from nukes and
oil and the normally kept up by selling
that oil russia
doesn't really have much i mean it
certainly tries to act like it does
but anyone familiar with the russian
economy knows that this is not the case
you know we were talking about a country
whose export is more than 60 percent
petroleum products which is kind of like
building your house on quicksand
because oil prices can fluctuate wildly
as the saying in political circles goes
the oil hits a hundred dollars putin
invades ukraine the oil hits 40 dollars
putin holds a conciliatory speech in the
reichstag
and as of making this video the price of
oil per barrel is
63 dollars and three cents so is there
an actual imminent danger of russia
invading ukraine
not right now if russia did go ahead
with it the costs would be simply too
high
rather the staging of russian troops on
the border of ukraine and crimea
are used as a tool of consolidation for
basically all parties
for putin he gets to posture as the
eastern macho dude
with the empire behind him i guess you
know protecting all the russians all
around the globe
showing the decadent west what's what
and trying to whip up some kind of
patriotic fervor in russia
to help stop his falling approval
ratings
meanwhile the ukrainian president
vladimir zelensky uses the crisis to
accelerate ukraine's accession into the
nato and potentially to the eu
and rallies the people against the
common enemy thus consolidating his
popular support
and you know it helps a lot that the
enemy this time is very much real
and for biden this crisis is an
excellent tool to solidify u.s european
relations
and to consolidate european powers
against putin and also to potentially
stop north stream 2
this highly debated gas pipeline between
germany and russia
bypassing ukraine which would then
reduce ukraine's relevance and incomes
etc etc it's a long story and i'll be
making a video about it soon because
it's a very interesting one
so this is it i suppose this is all the
sides to the
crisis on the ukrainian border right now
things don't point to world war 3 yet
just some international feuds disputes
and
domestic rallying of support and
consolidation of voter blocks
but the crisis did produce a very
interesting situation in the czech
republic which could almost be called a
domestic political crisis
one that involves two ammunition depots
of the czech army
and two russian secret agents the same
ones who actually poisoned sergey
skripal in the uk with novichok
so stay tuned because i'll be making a
video about that next
and it's really entertaining slash
horrifying
in the meantime if you have any inputs
about the ukrainian crisis please let me
know in the comments
and i'll be seeing you soon oh and like
and subscribe all of that
thanks for watching